[Musique]
vous devriez aller chercher un autre endroit pour aller
attendre dans la région de la voiture
[Musique]
nous sommes actuellement un groupe de personnes
qui partagent un ennemi commun, ce qui en fait
ce que nous appellerons une alliance
inspirante
[Applaudissements]
vous n'  je ne veux pas voir ce que
je dis vraiment j'aime vraiment être de retour allons-nous le
voir non vous n'êtes pas
les gens qui nous ont attaqués se sont battus à l'
unisson ils étaient parfaitement coordonnés
nous ne le sommes pas
ils font passer la violence pour un art
qui sont  hé qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent ils
me veulent elle fait partie de la
prophétie pour travailler ensemble nous devons voir
ce que l'autre peut faire d'accord d'accord
tu me demandes nu ouais mais
ça vaudra le coup
[Musique]
imagine l'électricité  courir à travers
tout ton corps
tu commences à te sentir fort comme si tu pouvais faire
n'importe quoi comme si tu respirais oh tu
veux rugir pas parce que tu es en colère
parce que tu veux juste tout laisser sortir
alors
rugis te snick